بين هذه المشاهد وتلك اكثر من عقدين من
الزمن وكثير من التحولات لسياسه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحولات يقول
كثيرون ان هذه الصور كانت الفيصله فيها
على تركيا وعلى محيطها
فمنذ المحاوله الانقلابيه في صيف 2016 سلك
الرجل طريق الانفتاح ليس على الداخل فحسب
بل الخارج ايضا
منذ بدايه العقد الاخير فتح الرجل ابواب
بلده للجماعه وقياداتها لا سيما بعد
فرارهم من مصر وسوريا غير انه عاد وقرر
نجم الجماعه ومنصاتها الاعلاميه عقب مد يد
التقارب مع مصر وحتى مع النظام السوري
بشكل ما
خلال الاعوام الماضيه شهدت العلاقات
التركيه توترا واصل الى ما يشبه القطيعه
مع دول خليجيه لكن اردوغان عاد لاصلاح
العلاقات ماخوذا بالمصلحه التركيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه لم يخفي اردوغان
رغبته بلقاء بشار الاسد والتعاون معه حتى
وصلت الاوضاع حد تشكيل اللجنه مشتركه
للتطبيع واعاده اللاجئين الى المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه
شكل القوميون حجر الزاويه في تحالفات
اردوغان الداخليه والانتخابيه
فالتحالف مع حزب الحركه القوميه مكن الرجل
من حسم التحول الى النظام الرئاسي عام
والانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2018
تحالفات اختتمها اردوغان مع القومي
المتشدد سنان اوجان للفوز بالانتخابات
الاخيره
اردوغان الفائز اليوم وان احتفظ بخطابه
الديني الثقافي اليوم الا انه لم يعد بحسب
الكثيرين اردوغان الاسلامي بل اردوغان
القومي اتى تركيا رغما عن الاتاتوركين
بعيدا عن خطاب مطلع الالفيه والتغيير كن
دائما امبرغماتيا فالواقع يقول
اردوغان اليوم غير اردوغان الامس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات